in the last month or two there's been a
measurable increase in the attention to
a wide variety of smaller math channels
on YouTube my friend James and I ran a
second iteration of a contest that we
did last year the summer of math
Exposition which invites people to put
up lessons about math online could be a
video could be an article any medium you
dream up whatever topic you dream up and
we have some prizes available for the
ones that we deem in some sense best
whatever that could mean the deadline
for submissions was a little over a
month ago and if we just focus on the
video entries they've collectively
accumulated over 7 million views since
that time considering that the vast
majority of these are uploaded to very
young channels where the video is often
just the first or the second upload this
was really exciting for me to see I
suspect a big part of the reason for
this Rising tide is that after the
submission deadline we ran a peer review
process where an algorithm would feed
participants two different videos to
compare and they'd be asked to vote
which one of these is quote better
according to a few criteria
now that process generated over 10 000
comparisons which on the one hand helps
to provide an initial rough rank
ordering of all the videos but more
important than that any judgments or
rankings it gave an excuse for many
hundreds of people to upload around a
similar time and then collectively view
each other's work helping to jump start
a cluster of videos with a shared viewer
base and that 7 million number doesn't
account for other videos on these
channels for instance the mini
submissions people made to last year's
contest which since this year's deadline
could electively jumped up by about 2
million views one group who told me that
last year's contest was what inspired
them to put up their first video
mentioned to me that a video they had
made in between the two contests managed
to suddenly jump from 1000 to 600 000
views during the peer review process for
this year's contest despite not being
among those videos reviewed this is all
to say there can be a surprising value
in the seemingly simple presence of a
shared goal and a shared deadline and
again these are just the video entries
where it's easy for us to run these
analytics to quickly get us sense of the
reach many of my favorite entries were
the written ones
the contest as you can no doubt tell is
getting more people to put out math
lessons and on that front mission
accomplished but I did promise to select
five winners lessons that stood out as
especially valuable for one reason or
another and that brings us to this video
here to choose winners James and I both
spent a couple weeks giving a pretty
thorough look at over 100 of the top
entries as determined by the peer review
process and we also recruited a few
guest judges from the community to help
look at a subset of these and make sure
that our own biases and blind spots
aren't playing too heavy a role many
many things to them in the time they
offered I won't tell you the final
decision until the end of the video what
I thought might be more fun is to lead
up to it by talking through the criteria
that I had in mind when making this
election highlighting as many exemplary
submissions as I can along the way
hopefully giving any of you who are
looking to put out your own math lessons
online at some point a few concrete
things to focus on at a high level the
four criteria I told people I'd look out
for were motivation Clarity novelty and
memorability the first two are probably
probably the most important and let's
start with motivation this actually has
two meanings I can think of one on the
macro scale and one on the micro scale
by macro scale motivation I mean how
well do you hook someone into the lesson
as a whole this video by Alexander
bairdnikov opens by asking why it is
that when you hear a plane approaching
the pitch of its sound seems to slowly
fall he points out how a lot of people
assume that this is the Doppler effect
but that this doesn't actually hold up
to scrutiny since for example that pitch
actually Rises as the plane is going
away from you it's a good point and an
interesting question you have my
attention
one of my favorite articles in the batch
by ADI mittal prompts you to wonder
about an algorithm behind the Panorama
feature on your phone and proceeds to
explain one why that's not trivial and
then two the linear algebra and
projective geometry involved in a DIY
style project to stitch together two
overlapping images taken at different
angles application and tangible problems
can make for great motivation but that's
not the only source of motivation
depending on the target audience a good
nerd sniping question can also do the
trick this video on the channel going
null opens with a seemingly impossible
puzzle 10 prisoners are each given a hat
chosen arbitrarily from 10 total hat
types available it is possible for some
of the prisoners to have the same Hat
type as others and everyone can see all
of the other hats but not their own
after given a little time to look at
everyone else's hat and think about it
all the prisoners are to simultaneously
shout out a guess for their own Hat type
the question is can you find a method
that guarantees at least one of the
prisoners will make a correct guess
this video by Eric Roland motivates the
idea of periodic numbers than the piatic
metric by showing how if you take 2 to
the tenth and 2 to the 100th 2 to the
one thousandth so on and so on and you
assign distinct colors to each digit
lining them all up on the right you can
see that their final digits line up more
and more with larger powers
then he asks the question of whether
it's reasonable to interpret this as a
kind of convergence despite the fact
that these numbers are clearly diverging
to Infinity in the usual sense
a completely different form of
motivation can come from showing the
historical significance of a problem or
field in a sense giving the viewer a
feeling that they're part of something
bigger one excellent video on a channel
a well-rested dog provides an overview
of the history of calculus and the
progression of how some of the world's
smartest Minds grappled with the nuances
of infinity and infinitesimals it's the
right mixture of entertaining and
detailed and he goes on to talk about
how learning all of this made his own
questions and confusions in a Calculus
class feel validated which I think a lot
of students can resonate with this
example is less about the intro of a
video motivating the lesson it teaches
and more about the entire video
motivating an entire field and another
one like that would be this lecture by
the Channel History laying out how
cantor's diagonalization argument and
the halting problem and a number of
other paradoxes people might have heard
of in math computer science and logic
all actually follow the same basic
pattern and moreover if you try to
formalize the exact sense in which they
follow the same pattern that ends up
serving as a pretty nice motivation for
the subject of category Theory
and the last flavor of motivation I'll
mention is if you can somehow make the
learner feel like they're playing an
active role in the lesson this is very
hard to do with a video maybe even
impossible and it's best suited for
in-person lessons but one written entry
that I thought did this especially well
was an inverse Turing test where you as
the reader are challenged to come up
with a sequence of ones and zeros that
appears random and the article goes on
to explain various statistical tests
that you could apply to prove that the
sequence was actually human generated
and not really random
the content of the article is centered
around the particular sequence that you
the reader created and you're invited to
change it along the way to try to get it
to pass more tests it's a nice touch and
I could easily see this working really
well as a classroom activity
whatever approach you take whatever
flavor of motivation is your favorite
it's hard to overstate just how
important it is that you do actually
give viewers a reason to care this is
true for any piece of content but I
think it's especially true for
educational content and even more so for
math given the amount of focus and
thought that these topics sometimes
require
I think this was articulated best by the
author of one of my favorite podcasts an
opinionated history of mathematics who
has a Manifesto on his website that lays
out what he calls the axioms of learning
beginning with the first Axiom but in a
perfect world students pursue learning
not because it is prescribed to them but
rather out of a genuine desire to figure
things out it follows that we must not
introduce any topic for which we cannot
first convince the students that they
should want to pursue it
that said one mistake that I think I've
made in past videos is to over
philosophize in the video's introduction
motivation is critical but it doesn't
have to take long and often what
actually keeps the viewer engaged is to
get right to the point and leave any
commentary about broader themes and
connections to the end if you can
motivate using clear examples not
sweeping statements or Promises of what
is to come
by micro scale motivation what I mean is
whether each new idea that's introduced
in the lesson itself feels to the
learner like it has a good reason to be
there for instance this video by Joshua
meros gives a fairly detailed overview
of Ray tracing and what I love about it
is that before he introduces any new
technical topic like the rendering
equation important sampling or the
restore algorithm he's already outlined
the main idea and intuition for that
topic with really well visualized
examples it makes it so that once the
equation comes on the screen or the
algorithm is described it doesn't feel
like an expression handed down with
nothing to hold on to instead it arrives
only once it's articulating something
that already exists at least Loosely in
the viewer's mind making it much easier
to parse
this video by Michael DeFranco about
extending the factorial offers another
great example of a lesson with good
motivation along the way
you may have heard that there's a
function generalizing the factorial to
real and even complex inputs the gamma
function the usual definition is written
down as a certain integral expression
sort of handed down from on high and the
justification for why this generalizes
factorials is certain properties that
you can prove about it but a lot of
students find this unsatisfying where
does it come from
by contrast in Michael's explanation he
starts by observing the properties that
are true of the normal factorial
function that you would want to be true
of a general version and uses those
desired properties to motivate various
different alternate Expressions massaged
here and there to be more amenable to
non-hole number inputs ultimately
leading to a pretty satisfying answer
another good template for this micro
scale motivation when introducing a
pretty complicated solution to a problem
is to start with a naive but flawed
solution and then progressively refine
it this article by Max Slater on
differential programming does this
particularly well the basic question is
how you get computers to evaluate
derivatives a ubiquitous task for
machine learning he starts by describing
the most obvious approach and then what
flaws it has and uses that as motivation
for another approach but that one has
its own flaws in fixing those motivates
yet another approach and so on the ideas
he builds up to dual numbers and
backward mode automatic differentiation
both could feel a bit confusing if
presented out of the blue but in context
having motivated each new idea by
pointing out flaws with the previous
ones it all ends up feeling utterly
reasonable turning back to that same
prisoner hat puzzle I referenced earlier
one of the other things I liked about it
is how the author doesn't just present
the solution there are plenty of puzzle
videos out there which do that instead
he gives a pretty authentic look at the
wrong turns and tangents that are
involved in the problem-solving process
not even eating up too much time to do
so and he justifies each new step with a
general problem-solving principle all of
this microscale motivation could just as
well be categorized as a subset of
clarity if motivating a lesson
determines how much attention and focus
the viewer is willing to give you
Clarity determines how quickly you burn
through that Focus the best hook in the
world is wasted if the lesson which
follows is confusing
this presentation by explanaria talks
about how to describe various Crystal
structures using group Theory which
considering the complex 3D forms
involved and the fact that most people
don't know group theory has the
potential to be very confusing but they
do a really effective job at keeping
concrete examples front and center
guiding the reader to focus on one
relevant pattern at a time and
Distilling down to a simple version of
an idea before seeing how that fits into
a broader more general setting
in general entries that struck me as
especially clear would often keep one or
two examples front and center and they'd
often give a feeling of playing with
those examples maybe running simulations
or tweaking them to run up against edge
cases and all around giving the viewer a
chance to build their own intuitions
before general rules are presented
the example doesn't even have to be
explicit in a visually driven lesson the
choice of what to show on screen when
making General points is often a great
opportunity to offer the viewer a
concrete example to hold on to but
without wasting too much time explicitly
talking about that example or over
emphasizing its importance this I think
is part of what gives visually driven
lessons the opportunity to be clearer as
a brief side comment by the way Loosely
related to Clarity for any of you who
want to use music in the videos while
music can enrich the storytelling aspect
of a lesson setting the desired tone and
the momentum once you're getting into
the meat of a technical explanation it's
very easy for the music to do more harm
than good if it's there at all you'll
want it to be decidedly in the
background and not calling attention to
itself
I recognize some hypocrisy here it's
definitely something I know I've messed
up with past videos and it's just worth
thinking about whatever benefit you see
from the music you don't want to incur a
needless cost on Clarity that outweighs
that benefit
moving on to novelty this is another
category that has two distinct
interpretations one would be stylistic
originality back when I created this
channel part of the reason I wrote my
own animation tool behind it was to
ensure a kind of stylistic originality
well the main reason was it was a fun
side project and having my hands deep
into the guts of some tool helped me to
feel less constrained in trying to
visualize whatever came to mind but
being a forcing function for originality
was at least a small part of my
reasoning this means there's at least a
little hint of irony in the fact that if
we fast forward to today so many of the
entries in this contest use that tool
manam to illustrate their lessons I have
nothing wrong with that it actually
Delights me it's why I made it open
source and I'm very grateful to the
manam community for everything they've
done to make the tool more accessible
but I would still encourage people to
find their own unique voice and
aesthetic whatever tools they use and
whoever they take inspiration from I
don't want to overemphasize that point
because it's the much less important
half of novelty the much more important
kind of novelty is when the thing you
present would have been very hard to
find Elsewhere on the internet either
because it's a highly unique topic or
because it's a very unique perspective
for example this video on percolation
showed a completely fascinating toy
model for studying phase changes a model
where it's easier to make exact proofs
and considering the level of depth and
the level of clarity that the authors
provided I think it's fair to say you
wouldn't find something like this on
YouTube if this group hadn't made it
as to memorability I'll keep this one
quick lessons take off this box when
they ask a question that's just so fun
to think about or provide such a
satisfying aha moment that it stays with
you long after watching it or reading it
admittedly this one is highly personal
and subjective to my taste for example
this video by Daria Ivanova discusses
the question of when it's possible for a
single track to have been left by a
bicycle that is the back wheel goes
through the same path that the front
wheel does which is just so fun to think
about
this video by gurgly bensic about how
involute gears work had a really
satisfying way of explaining why a
certain gear design pattern works so
well that for me at least just stuck
so with all of that who are The Chosen
winners in the announcement I promised
that one winner slot would go to an
entry that was made as a collaboration
and that one goes to the percolation
video the other four windows are perhaps
unsurprisingly also ones that I've
already mentioned
they include the post about describing
Crystal structures with group Theory the
video covering the history of calculus
the one about Ray tracing and the
algorithms to make it faster and the
problem-solving lesson centered around a
tricky hat riddle these entries really
do speak for themselves so rather than
telling you too much more here I
encourage you to check them out to be
honest after I got it down to about 25
entries that I wanted to at least be
honorable mentions it was exceedingly
hard to actually choose winners from
that since for each of these I could
easily Envision a target audience for
whom that entry would actually be the
best recommendation it was a game of
comparing apples to oranges but times
25. below the video I've left links to
the other 20 that I chose as honorable
mentions and to a playlist that contains
all the video submissions and also to a
blog post containing links to all of the
non-video submissions
thanks to a sponsorship from brilliant
each winner will get a thousand dollars
as a cash prize and also and much more
importantly I think a rare Edition
golden pie creature also after the
initial announcement risk zero and
Google fonts both generously reached out
offering additional prize sponsorships
I'd also like to thank protocol labs for
another contribution to help us cover
the costs of managing the whole event
thanks to everybody who participated and
to everybody who helped in creating this
Rising tide for new math channels and
new math blogs that we've seen in the
last month it was genuinely inspiring to
see just how well this all went
[Music]
thank you
[Music]